Nice to meet you all who are watching Anti-Roll. It
's a total of 15 patterns that I'm worried about.
It's written like "I'm like a
voice actor" or "Why
don't you do a voice actor's job?"
Among the customers who came
, that company of casting who does voice work came and gave me a
voice sample, so it may be possible to get a job,
so I asked him to say that I want to be Hayashi.  So
it's okay to be a member of the theater company, and I sent a voice sample and handed it over
.
I think 10 years is very long, but
rather than being surprised at the length, the episode that it becomes one by one is very much.  There was
a lot of good content, so the
weight is 10 years long, and the weight is more memorable for me.
I think it's a very normal sensation.  A child who cries when he wants
to give out good or bad, good or bad,
honestly, but sometimes he looks good and I think he is a normal person
For example
, if you're a kid, I think everyone remembers it, but when you're
heading for a tantrum, you might hit something violent, for
example, or
shoot a bang bang beyond yourself.  I think
that there
will be times when they will rub against each other, but since it is very different each time
, there is the power of nine tails in the body,
and even if you cause a primary tantrum, the power is too great and it is
dangerous, isn't it?
I think that it was required because it was a small thing that I had to control it, but the
person himself won and kicked more and more, right now,
so I think that Naruto will be at the timing that
Naruto thinks.  I'm thinking of improving myself, so I don't think I'd say that I should fix this, and I do
n't think it's going to happen.
How to use
that power  It
's not been 10 years since I started thinking about how to use it, but
I think it's growing by thinking about various things every moment.
What's the rest
?  Around
me Around me I think I'm starting to
think like I'm thinking about it.
It's a great success, isn't it? I think it's
amazing.
Naturally, it's amazing when it comes to acting like that.  I have a lot of thoughts,
so I think
about what I'm doing, and I wonder what's going on around me, not myself.
I think it's great that I started thinking about what to do when I stood up,
but
after that, my body is growing steadily, so
it seems that I'm getting lower in line with that
.
I have a
frontier spirit.  I love it, so rather than aiming for someone, my
motto is to open up my own path and cry if I fail
. There is no one for the time being, but the ancestors are wonderful people
.
I'm thinking of learning each one and doing
my best, but I think the
most important thing
is that I like myself the most.
Absolutely the work we are doing.  I think that I am a filter and define one character to the
customer, so
if I dislike myself, I will let people know with a filter I dislike.
First of all, I think that I feel that I believe and love myself the most
.
Yes,
I'm going to Rambo. I want to get you.
While saying that, if I'm worried about my wife, I'm more and more distorted in
my words-that's my anger
If you keep up with this, that face-washing
rock cafe only talks about personnel affairs  However, there is one
power
here.
Hmm. 8 Excuse me for the gift
. I'm Akamaru dog, but I have a stuffed animal of this size, but it's
cute.  What?  By the way,
Akamaru I was there.
Yes,
this is a
lot yes
.
I like the onomatopoeia